on Thursday left-wing fact-checker
PolitiFact a site known more for its
biases than its quality fact-checking
stepped into a pile of doodoo once again
this time they blasted President Trump
with a fake news fact check that
demonstrates just how dishonest they are
here is there a headline White House
tweet wrongly says Obamacare led to
fewer insurance options and they mostly
false so what did the White House say
that was so wrong Trump said quote
Obamacare has led to fewer health
insurance options for millions of
Americans this is indisputably true
just yesterday Anthem Blue Cross pulled
out of the Obamacare exchanges in
Wisconsin in Indiana health insurance
rates have risen dramatically at CNBC
reported last week quote as many as
1,200 counties are projected to have
just one such insurer next year more
counties could be left bare or with just
one insurer in coming weeks as insurers
announce their intentions unquote and
this doesn't take into account the fact
that many Obama care plans have cut
patients off from their doctors if you
like your doctor you couldn't keep your
doctor those who have been added to the
insurance rolls under Obamacare aren't
actually buying health insurance for the
most part they're being forced under
Medicaid by lack of options so instead
of dealing with that claim PolitiFact
made up an unrelated claim that the
number of on that the number of insured
had dropped overall nobody said that
though if you count Medicaid coverage
which doesn't actually improve health
outcomes the numbers are up but that's
not what Trump claimed here's PolitiFact
admitting the truth all the way at the
bottom of their little fact check quote
the soil threat of truth is that what
the insurance exchanges set up by the
law the number of carriers has wind 'old
oh you mean the only claim here that
Trump made was true and then you made up
a series of alternative claims you knock
down
PolitiFact is ridiculous their drive to
check fake news from the left only makes
them purveyors of that same fake news
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
okay so they finally just released the
Senate healthcare version the Obamacare
and quote-unquote repeal it is not a
repeal it is even more of a trash heap
than the House version that passed I was
very critical of that version version
one was really bad version two was
slightly less bad the Senate version is
really quite crappy it's going to pass
probably and the reason that it will
pass I would think is because of two
things one it defund Planned Parenthood
and two it basically allows Republicans
to go out there and claim that they
repealed Obamacare when they did no such
thing
but we'll talk about that a little while
after I want to discuss Trump in Iowa
but before we do any of those things I
first want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at my Patriot supply so if
you are a smart person you know that you
also prepare for emergencies there are
going to be situations in life where
there's some sort of natural disaster or
that's a bit a man-made disaster where
the government can't get to you right
away there's an earthquake there's a
flood there's a tornado there's a
terrorist attack and you need food for
your family well that's where my Patriot
supply comes in right now you can go to
prepare with been calm it's prepare with
been calm and you get there floor week
emergency food supply for just $99 their
number is eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 or online and prepare with
been calm it's 99 bucks plus free
shipping that feeds a family of four or
it gets there a four week emergency food
supply rather my team tells me the meals
taste like homemade cooking they've all
tried it in the office again it's
prepared with been calm prepare with
been calm make sure that you and your
family are safe
888 803 1413 888 803 1413 prepare with
been calm and that ensures that you and
your family are safe again so one time
spend ain't that much money you should
do it just to be the responsible person
that you are okay so I do want to talk
about the Senate version of Trump Care /
Obamacare repeal before we get to that I
think it's important to talk about the
Democrats and their aftermath of their
reaction to the loss of John Asaf in
Georgia sixth against karen handel so
finally all of the conflict has been
brewing under the surface of the
resistance is broken open the hatred for
Trump covered up the fact that the
Democrats really have nothing in common
anymore there are three branches of the
Democratic Party
and they are at war with one another one
is the Bernie Sanders branch this is the
Progressive Socialist Michael Moore
branch of the party that says capitalism
is evil and we need to redistribute all
the income and all the problems in the
country are created by income inequality
these people are not intersectional
politicians they believe that
socialistic redistribution ISM is the
solution and that the Democratic Party
has to universally move towards the left
that's branch number one branch number
two are the intersectional politician
this would be like Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton both of these
politicians their principles are a
little bit all over the place they're
often left obviously but they tend to
differ on certain basic functions of
government but they all agree that
America is a terrible place where human
beings are separated by race and sex and
sexual orientation see the intersection
unless you believe that they're going to
cobble together this new coalition of
people who have been victimized by the
American system in order to win
elections so again group number one the
Sanders people they say we move to the
left we'll win and then you'll group
number two and these are the the Obama
people and they say we need our
intersectional hierarchy the Hillary
people we need our intersectional
hierarchy and then there's group number
three and group number three are the
Seth Moulton of the world this is the
Democratic Congress person from
Massachusetts who's making the rounds
yesterday because he said what we need
is a broader tent party where we have
some pro-life Democrats where we have
some people who are not so anti business
where we are not universally Nancy
Pelosi Democrat and these three factions
are now at war with one another and
that's breaking out into the open
because Democrats for the first time are
realizing that it's not enough just to
scream at president Trump alone it's
going to get them most of the way but if
they have no unity if they can't figure
out what they're doing then they've got
a problem Rahm Emanuel acknowledged that
they are in serious trouble he says we
are 1,000 seats behind as the former
chief of staff for President Obama we
are a thousand seats shorter to date
than we were two oh nine or 208 this is
not about one election it's about
building a party building an apparatus
okay so they're finally realizing they
have bad news but the problem is their
response to that was Trump is colluding
with Russia when Hilary lost their
immediate response was we have to resist
what are we resisting well we can't say
what his agenda is because we don't know
what is Genda is from hasn't actually
done anything major at this point so it
resists him he's a putin's stooge
the one problem an entire theory is
following apart jeh Johnson who is the
former homeland security secretary under
President Obama helps contribute to the
collapse of the Democrats key talking
point that trump is some sort of Russian
stooge not beyond what has been out
there open-source and not beyond
anything that I'm sure this committee
has already seen and heard before
directly from the intelligence community
it's the only thing I'd have on that is
derivative of what the intelligence
community has and the law enforcement
community okay so you can see that with
that narrative falling apart they now
have to come up with a new narrative so
on the one hand you have the people who
are who are more in favor of this broad
tent democratic party that's the one
that's actually going to be better for
Democrats right this would be kind of
the Joe Biden wing of the party we need
to get beyond intersectional politics
representative Dingell who I guess
replaced I think she replaced her
husband right is Debbie Dingell she
spoke with MSNBC yesterday and she
talked about this she said that
basically we need to get beyond the
intersectional Obama era and we need to
move toward a more a more solid era of
we're all Americans and this is what
Democrats do if they were smart but
they're not so here's Debbie Dingell
from Michigan if we don't figure out how
we become we again we're going to keep
losing so I think it's important that we
need to understand each of these groups
past issues so she says we can't be
African Americans for for Obama or for
Hillary we can't be Hispanic Americans
for Obama or Hillary we have to just be
we again and this is true right this is
the real reason that Trump won the
reason Trump won is because he wasn't
insulting Americans by categorizing them
into small groups and then implying that
there was this broad vast white mass out
there those out to get them that's the
real reason the Trump won it wasn't
about his populist politics it wasn't
about tariffs was mad at stuff gay
wasn't about Ross dude had in the and
the tax credits that Trump would give to
particular businesses in the Rust Belt
it was about the fact that Trump did not
patronize a bunch of white voters by
telling them they hated black and
Hispanic people that's what actually
happened here
so you have this wing of the party the W
Dingell wing that is starting to figure
it out unfortunately for Debbie Dingell
that's being undercut by the Bernie
Sanders wing to the Bernie Sanders wing
says that Nancy Pelosi should continue
to rule the party Nancy Pelosi is a
wonderful far-left politician who's just
done yeoman's work even though
it was Nancy Pelosi's name just being
dropped a couple of times in the Georgia
six that led to the Democratic defeat
Pappagallo says we can't get rid of
Nancy Pelosi we need Nancy Pelosi but
every time that he was please click
defense event there was a Mount Rushmore
for speakers Nancy Pelosi would be on it
she passed national health care even
Franklin Roosevelt could not do that I
mean she is so important we need to keep
her we need to run far to the left we
need to become the Bernie Sanders party
so that's wing number two and then
finally there is the intersectional wing
so what here's what Democrats need to
unify okay so and this is where it's
kind of interesting what's going on
right now because I think it plays into
what Democrats need in order to unify
what Democrats need in order to unify is
not only for Trump to be unpopular but
for there to be some piece of
legislation that they can all jump on
and smack him with so in 1994 Bill
Clinton was very unpopular but it took
Hillary care and the threat of Hillary
care to lead to this vast Republican
wave that wiped out 60 seats in the in
the house for Democrats and led to the
rise of the Republican majority in the
house that has basically been steady
with with the brief period between oh 6
and 10 since 1994 so the fact is that
you need two things in order for the
outer party the out of power party to
take over what they need is an unpopular
president number one and then that that
goes into mess and then you need an
enzyme to catalyze the resistance and
that is some piece of unpopular
legislation
well so far Trump hasn't actually done
anything right so far the only thing
he's done is nominating Al Gore such and
that's not enough of a slap Democrats
for them to really catalyze around it
for them to coagulate around that and
then become the quote/unquote resistance
and so Chuck Schumer is interested in
Obamacare appeal he thinks that the
Democrats are going to be able to whip
the the base into a fury over the repeal
of the supposed repeal of Obamacare
we're going to look at every single
thing and find out the best way but this
is full-scale warfare this is the most
important advancement since probably
Medicare in terms of helping people and
we're not going to be complacent or go
along or business as usual in any way so
Democrats need something to oppose they
need Trump not just to be Trump they
need Trump to actually push a big piece
of Legends
relation that is unpopular fortunately
for them it looks like the Senate is
about to do that so the Senate just
dropped their health care bill and the
Senate health care bill is just a
disaster the Senate health care bill it
cuts some of the Obamacare taxes but the
problem is then it doesn't pay for all
the subsidies that it's giving it's
preserving virtually all of the
Obamacare subsidies it's increasing
subsidies in certain areas it cuts
Medicaid but it only does that down the
road and those cuts were never going to
materialize it enshrines the Obamacare
central regulations in place will
Republicans pass it as I said I think
they probably will because I think that
Republicans are stupid and they just
want the immediate headline that they
repealed Obamacare even though that
means they now own what comes next they
also want to be able to say to their
constituency that they repealed all the
funding for Planned Parenthood although
again is that a big enough deal to is
that is that a huge enough advance for
the Republicans who own Obamacare for
the foreseeable future no it's sort of
reminiscent of what President Trump did
with illegal immigration he said that he
was going to get rid of DAPA which is
the protection for parents of illegal
immigrants who came in when they were
children
he got rid he said he's getting rid of
DAPA which wasn't even in place and then
he Brehon shrined daca which was Obama's
executive amnesty Republicans are
basically reinsuring Obama care and then
calling it Obamacare repeal which is the
worst of all available world even the
creator even the creator of Obamacare
Jonathan Gruber remember he's the guy
who was caught on tape saying yes we
lied to the American public about what
Obamacare was going to do even he is now
out there saying that this Senate
version doesn't actually repeal
Obamacare in any significant way does
this bill have more heart as the
president would say Jonathan you know
I'm torn this morning on the one hand
this is no longer the Obamacare repeal
bill that's good on the other hand this
is just a giant cut and Medicaid that's
what this bill now amounts to huh and
that's bad okay and so he's he's upset
about the Medicaid cuts but he says that
basically Trump care is Obamacare and
this is essentially correct there's a
poll that just came out from NBC Wall
Street Journal they found only 34
percent of Republicans like the House
GOP health care bill and only 16% of
Americans overall say that that House
GOP health care bill is a good idea the
Senate GOP health care bill is in many
ways even worse
Peter Sudirman over
komm has a good rundown on what exactly
is in the bill what he says is the
senate plan looks even closer to the
health-care law that is already on the
books in other words it is exactly what
critics predicted a bill that at least
in the near term retains weakened
versions of nearly all of Obamacare
score features while fixing few if any
of the problems Republicans say they
want to fix it is Obamacare life the
health law Republicans claim to oppose
but less of it it represents a total
failure of Republican policy imagination
and then he goes on he says to
understand the Senate plan it helps to
recall Obama cares underlying framework
the centerpiece of the law was a reform
of the individual market intended to
give those who do not get coverage
through work or a federal program access
to subsidized regulated coverage the law
created a new federal subsidy based on
income for lower and middle-income
households to purchase health insurance
it also set up federal rules requiring
insurers to cover pre-existing
conditions and a mandated that all
individuals obtain health coverage to
pay for it so basically it created what
we know as Obamacare created these
Obamacare markets and the idea was we're
going to force all of the insurers to
cover people with pre-existing health
conditions how do we pay for that by
forcing people who are healthy to buy
health insurance that was the basic
structure of Obamacare so what does the
Republican Senate bill do it keeps in
place all the regulations it removes the
mandate it removes some of the taxes so
it keeps all of the mandates on
insurance companies which means that the
so-called Obamacare death spiral will be
accelerated all these insurance
companies are going to be forced to take
on people they can't afford and nothing
makes up the gap except for more
government subsidies those government
subsidies of course come from borrowing
and Republicans are cutting the taxes so
they won't come from taxes the reason
Republicans are cutting Medicaid in the
future is they're playing an accounting
game what they're hoping to do is come
across as revenue neutral in fact
they're hoping that this quote unquote
saves revenue to the federal government
even though it really will not in the
long run so they can pack pass tax
reform that's the goal here if you
understand that the Obamacare repeal
plan from the Senate is designed to do
two things neither of which is repealing
Obamacare you'll understand all you need
to know about this Obamacare repeal
program it is designed to number one
tell Republicans that it repealed
Obamacare without actually repealing it
and number two it is designed to make
room for tax cut under reconciliation
under reconciliation in order for
Republicans to pass a bill through the
Senate with 51 votes instead of 60
necessary to shut down a filibuster
Republic
have to get a score from the
Congressional Budget Office that says
that any bill that they pass is quote
unquote revenue neutral pay tax cuts are
not revenue neutral because in the short
term at least they reduce the amount of
money that comes into the federal
government so Republicans are trying to
do is pass a health care bill that cuts
the amounts of outlay by the federal
government so they can then take that
amount and translate it into a tax
reform bill so all the Republicans
really want from Obamacare repeal is the
headline that says they repealed it even
though they didn't and to the ability to
pass a tax cut that's it that's all this
is and so the Senate bill accomplishes
both those goals but it doesn't actually
repeal Obamacare Republicans have
criticized these marketplaces as
sudirman says for being expensive and
unstable Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell says Obamacare is collapsing
around us yet even more than a house
plan the Senate plan retains the
essential structure of Obama cares
individual market reforms it would
likely result in fewer people being
covered and it would not stop the
destabilization of the market so it
doesn't actually help anybody it creates
a permanent subsidy you know right now
under Obamacare there are subsidies that
go up to 400 percent of the poverty line
for a family of four so if you are
trying to buy health care in the Obama
care plan you get some sort of subsidy
up to 400% of the poverty that's about a
hundred thousand dollars for a family of
four starting in 2020 the Senate bill
wraps that back to 350 percent of the
poverty line about eighty six thousand
dollars for the same family
well that hurts the middle class people
who have been reliance on those
subsidies and - we shouldn't be
subsidizing this stuff anyway okay the
idea that we should be subsidizing a
family of four that makes a hundred
thousand dollars a year to buy Obama
care it doesn't actually help anything
in the sense that it continues to drive
up costs because healthy people are
still not getting insured once you
remove the mandate so if you have an
unhealthy family of four even with the
subsidy they lose money if they're
healthy then they shouldn't really need
the subsidy should they so it's this
bizarre situation it's an entitlement
program basically that Republicans are
signing off on and then they're
proposing to authorize certain payments
called CSR payments
these are cost-sharing reduction
subsidies to insurers so we are now
going to subsidize the insurance
companies even the same way that Obama
was going to remember Obama tried to
subsidize the insurers and Republicans
sued to stop him and now Republicans are
going to backtrack on
Republicans are now going to provide the
same subsidies they sued Obama for
providing under the Senate version so
the reports by the way indicate that
those subsidies for families before
they're pegged to lower-cost plans which
means smaller subsidies for crappier
health insurance as Sudirman says the
scheme undercuts the GOP complaint
Obamacare hurts the middle class in
addition to higher deductibles it
creates a subsidy cliff for middle-class
families purchasing health insurance on
the individual market and of course it
still spends an enormous amount of money
so if you look at the Senate bill and
how it handles Medicaid it's like the
House bill this is the one good
parenthood part it slowly rolls back
Medicaid expansion over a period of
years and converts it into a per capita
system rather than a need-based system
but it's it delays the start of that
phase out until 2021 which means it's
never going to happen because a
Republican president and Republican
Congress would have to be elected from
here all the way aural 2020 in order to
ensure that this kicks in otherwise the
Democrats will come in and they'll just
roll it back and says starting in 2025
who places stricter cap on the growth of
Medicaid spending than the House bill
yeah except by 2025 who thinks that
Republicans are going to be able to
withhold the pressure all the way to
2025 anybody anybody if you this is the
way that the legislation works folks it
says in 10 years we're going to do act
it's never happening because somebody
from the other party will come in and
destroy it before the 10 years are up
this is all it's just it's a bad bill
it's a bad bill Sudirman says this might
be the notable failure to think beyond
the terms set by Obamacare means the
Senate bill not only won't the Obamacare
repeal it might not even be Obamacare
light instead it might be Obamacare
light later and later could easily turn
out to be never because as the
individual insurance markets fail thanks
to the lack of a mandate and thanks to
the lack of taxes to pay for any of this
stuff then there's going to be more and
more call for government involvement not
less and less call or more more call for
free markets
bottom line is the Republicans in the
Senate in the house do not want to
repeal Obamacare
because they have all bought into the
basic notion that the government ought
to be involved in the health care system
which is a disaster for Republicans
Democrats won this debate and now
Republicans are surrendering to it so
the question becomes why the hell do you
elect Republicans in the first place
I'll get to that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at quip so quick is this
brand new too
brush company and it is just phenomenal
for two reasons one I used to have an
electric toothbrush they're heavy it's
hard to travel with them whenever I
would travel I would just bring a normal
toothbrush not an electric toothbrush
because they are so bulky and they just
fill up your suitcase quick is this
amazing electric toothbrush that packs
vibration and timer features into a very
slim design with a battery in it it's
basically like a Apple designed a
toothbrush but it doesn't have a big
price tag on it you have to see it
impress with it yourself it's really
terrific obviously I brush with it and
you can subscribe to receive new brush
heads on a dentist recommended three
month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping so one of the
problems with the electric toothbrushes
is if you forget to buy the extra head
then you're using the same head for the
next seven years which is disgusting
quick make sure that you get the new
head when you're supposed to get it as
that Brit dentists would recommend you
get in the mail without even having to
think about it right now go to get quick
comm slash up here to get your first
refill pack free with equip electric
toothbrush clip starts just 25 bucks by
the way so it's not like you're breaking
the bank for an electric toothbrush but
this does have health ramifications
there are pretty significant linkages
scientifically between plaque in your
mouth and and not brushing properly not
flossing properly and heart disease
apparently so go to quip comm slash
apparel get that first refill pack for
free with a quick electric toothbrush
you get that first refill pack free
again and get quick calm slash if your
oqu IP get quick calm slash Shapiro's
get quick calm slash repair you get that
first refill pack free and use the flash
capiro so that they know that we sent
you and they continue to advertise with
us okay so with all of this set the fact
that the tenant bill sucks right now we
are now learning there at least a couple
of Republican senators who are probably
not going to vote for it which means
that it may not pass at all the question
becomes do Republicans even long passed
this thing do Republicans you want to
pass this thing and it's not clear that
they do it's not clear that Republicans
actually want to do much of anything
because Republicans number one never
want to do much of anything because
they're afraid that if they do something
there will be a backlash and number two
because if you run the entire federal
government you pass something massive
again this could catalyze the left into
opposition for example take the Aussie
operation Georgia SiC so there were a
lot of people who are suggesting that
Asaf should have run more strip more
heavily on Trump care okay number one
that wasn't going to work because that's
a pretty Apple
district not a lot of people are on
obamacare to begin with in that district
and number two nothing has actually
passed it was hard to run against a
piece of legislation that doesn't
actually exist yet
if Republicans pass a very unpopular
piece of legislation which this looks
like it is then they will bear the
burden of that now imagine for a second
the Republicans had come in and just
fulfilled the basic promise we're going
to repeal Obamacare end of story one
sentence Obamacare is repealed but today
just come in and done that and then then
you go she entered around the edges for
what we're going to do to fix the
problems that Obamacare was designed to
solve then Republicans would be in
pretty good shape but now because
they're trying this omnibus fix to
Obamacare that doesn't actually fix it
leaves it in place increases subsidies
in certain areas decreases subsidies in
certain other areas gets rid of the
underlying mechanism for funding the
whole damn thing so we're just going to
borrow up the wazoo for it and then
pretend we're going to cut later if
Republicans do that then Democrats will
have something to coalesce around which
is silly because the fact is that if
you're gonna pass policies they ought to
be good policies if you're going to take
political risk it ought to be for a good
potential payoff there is an alternative
strategy that Republicans could pursue
if they really don't want to do anything
there's an alternative strategy that
they could pursue that unfortunately I
think unfortunately would actually work
with the Republican crowd it would also
prevent them from sustaining massive
losses in 2018 because they wouldn't
actually pass anything deeply unpopular
but for that you're going to have to go
over to Daley wired.com and become a
subscriber for just eight dollars a
month you can become a subscriber over
at Daley wire.com right now that is the
rate it can go up to I first you become
a subscriber now you can part of the
mailbag you can write in to me live on
the mailbag on Fridays you can also be
part of andrew clavin's mailbag see the
rest of the show live if you want an
annual subscription right now you had a
free signed copy of say it so talk about
baseball and my dad and me it's I think
a really fun terrific read say it so you
can get that for free sign when you get
an annual subscription also the annual
subscription rates are going to change
July 1st you want to get that annual
subscription right now if you're
thinking about it now is the time to do
it don't wait until July 1st just do it
right now if you don't want to subscribe
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud you can
listen to the rest of the show later
make sure you subscribe and leave a
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
you
[Music]